this is a second viewing cuz I only saw
this point first came out it had a great
laugh never looks back
a mission impossible to UM cruise
Boogaloo this is yeah I know what I said
Tom Cruise's ego at like the height of
his ego and Tom Cruise right now you
know it sounds like kind of cool and I
like he's actually kind of come a long
way and after given away his ego is
probably higher now it's just the films
aren't is reflective of that like it's
so nobody was here I have to admit I've
only seen the bad Mission Impossible
movies I've seen up to three I know
they're good cuz I read the Brad Bird
one's good I think the others have been
decent like ya know everyone says
they're good I've only seen the bad ones
they kind of finally settled on a tone
this one was so entertaining ly bad I
remember kind of having a ball with it
um I don't know if I still well maybe
I'll hate it now I don't know like this
I liked this one better than the third
one yeah me too there was just boring
mission impossible to attack of iego
mountain impossible they see that really
big star top as Tom Cruise does he
always has to be the biggest I know
where Hulk in a search for our hero
monster hamari confuse a scientist made
a monster just because yes scientist
makes monster in a mission impossible
it's like the most stereotypical old
scientist I must keep the secret formula
it will make months that I mentioned
foreign sounding names like Dmitry God
that hairstyle is awful just literally
says I am a dick probably used car
salesman and he needs a name like Maggs
powers and wears a leather jacket and
motorcycle and shows ok the airplane in
airplane looks more realistic than that
well there it is the movies already put
everyone to sleep
it's like fucking Scooby Doo
my egos too big I'll never climb it no
that's for Tom Cruise you need Everest
the CG down the millions of nets I wish
I could find a way to describe why this
doesn't work where the later films do
because he's doing well why yeah yeah
that's it there's no point this is
Louise setup say I'm cool now I'm at
this thing even hunt from the first
movie I'm like fucking Rambo but I still
have that same voice
it's like he just looks at the camera
like here we go again
this message will self-destruct in five
seconds what if he didn't take those
glasses off in time it's like he just be
totally defaced there's something when
did we end up in the mask save it just
our twist one of the dancers takes off
the mask s top crews that was him you
know if you actually take out all of the
slow-mo John woos films are only twenty
four minutes long touch Tom Cruise I
need these i iose Spain a country so
third world everything is candlelit no
seriously like do they not have electric
lights here you have unlocked the secret
of the water jets
yeah the first film is not good but at
least it's really attempting to be right
de palma so it's basically just like
okay I'm gonna do a dumbed down version
of a spy thriller this is just dumbed
down version of James Bond which is
already a dumbed down version of a
spider
yeah multiple levels of dumb yeah I
don't know just hard jagged diamonds
tucked between your boobs chafed a
little I don't know I was hoping we
might work together sounds terrific
that's actually how we casted her sounds
terrific I just jumped her in the hot
tub and says we should work together and
she said just like that sounds terrific
yeah he's a spy which means he has other
spy friends so odds are they're gonna
catch in the matter way if you want me
you gotta catch me okay slams on the
brakes and then just a copter like just
yes right in front of her it's like spy
remember bitch
this is when Hans Zimmer was internet
for a while know everybody was fucking
into that thing during this time I came
in from day one it was an avatars and
district nights in this shit's fucking
hated I hate Doug despised - the
crashing into me and dangling me off a
cliff you know I guess nothing you know
just cutting to other cultural things
doesn't make you suddenly important oh
this is about something no you're still
too shit this is how Hollywood gives us
culture you pick the whitest person on
the planet to wander around other
locales you mean it'll be difficult very
this is not mission difficult miss towns
its mission impossible Billy smart this
is the second time he's like you know I
our stage ends before so it's like this
is Mission Possible - like as well
spelled differently burning angels again
movie so deep I think John we were just
as given up on any sense of symbolism
he's just like find something to put in
background we have this image of Jesus
on a llama - it it's symbolic of what
Jesus on a llama
how many people are capable of something
like that
like what yeah lots he's a spy he stops
people from doing this would it make you
feel any better if I didn't want you to
do this yeah much and feel better but
just jealous cuz you want my hair I do
in the outback you couldn't do this in a
city somewhere no it's less suspicious
if we rent the only house in the outback
as the Asian Michael Bay he has to make
sure there's always sunsets there's
always red there's always a lot of
camera movement I mean come on why when
I see him I just see mr. Smithers
looking at mr. burns on a date and he's
gone yeah I like to see Ethan on just
smoke bomb I was looking for you and
then I saw this giant cloud of smoke and
should be even better if you didn't have
a smoke bomb it smoke bomb hey just by
the way it's like whoa his acting was so
good I thought there's a smoke bomb I
like how this guy is like okay I have to
act like Tom Cruise it's going like this
going like this is good it's like yeah
actually he's kind of giving his
inflections
you still Bellerophon I need it now
you're watching gypsy incorporate that
insult in my life said you worked out
Russian let's see well confused looks
yeah man that's original just a friendly
reminder would be out of contact with
eight minutes actually that wasn't for
you I know you already know that was for
the audience just a reminder you know
cuz you're a spy and you know you should
remember this shit but you know just a
reminder you just know this is killing
them cuz it's like eight minutes you
can't talk no it's okay you can just
look good yeah hmm he loves this we
needs oh no you know why I feel like I'm
watching an episode of Archer oh my god
the security is atrocious this is baby
frolics Tom why don't we take a chill
pill and we can discuss this gasps it's
the Riddler's hideout what's with the
green eye color scientists supposed to
work in this this makes no sense
get him that's a great plan get her
very scientific glad he said that
because we were just gonna stand around
and watch him get away but now you said
get them I I think it's a good plan well
you were knocking them off destroying
the very thing you came for now okay you
never see this in action wait I like
these talking and then he leans over
while talking shooting it's like they
never do that in movies like that cause
first as if to say I'm gonna shoot you
now yeah was your top bid why you're
gonna make me a better offer 37 million
pounds I literally eat that for
breakfast I eat money I'm talking swan
dive to the manual magton smell I feel
like pleading for your life that's just
a dumb line to feel like pleading for
your life like Oh zing we've established
he's just a creepy loser like he has no
good one lies he's got yeah he's
actually a very bored I get the feeling
this is somebody who wants to be a Bond
villain like he watched a lot of Bond
films he's like he's like syndrome from
in crayon was a way better villain yes I
feel like this movie does for Australia
what Blues Brothers 2000 did for Chicago
of course the other side of the island
we didn't think to look there yeah they
got all the people there with like the
barbed wire and stuff like that it's
like well someone could just swim up the
climb like it's almost a joke the way it
was it's like how we like twirled and
pure wetted him to death so how are you
taking out well he his legs got me and
he he spun me wouldn't he spongy world
okay it was elegant I've made Christmas
here we go is your money shot close it
was the dog the whole time hey babe
we have got to conclude our business
Oh give him this it's like explosion
Hampton town crews walked by it's like
no see let's just keep going to name you
peaceful husband crucified there's no
other security out there to see a
helicopter coming down I thought there's
a thousand-aire of eights is mission
impossible mission improbable that looks
like the most disinterested henchmen
firing a gun average si there it is
that's the scene where I knew we were in
fucking trouble where I'm like Tom
Cruise dressed like the fucking
terminator riding a motorcycle out of an
explosion
mission impossible yeah and yet there
was not nearly enough of that it's like
all saved in this last bit that means it
may may may amazing amazing amazing I'm
amazing I'm amazing an amazing amazing
now if he was so amazing that car would
have blown up on the first shot I had to
be someone realist
[Music]
oh that's a great time curries
impression Kenny now so close oh well
get the helicopter under you so you can
jump on the propellers it'll kill you
ways I get it I get it is symbolic of
the ocean yeah how does that work I
didn't want to kill you with a knife I'd
rather kill you with a gun cuz that's
the honorable way it's like what I'd
kiss you but I think you might still be
you Ian virus II just can't say the same
thing about you as for miss hall in
light of her efforts whatever the line
was I will be off there is a cronut with
my name on it right over there
and that wasn't in the script I don't
care
I feel like this is the end of a
romantic what the hell is going on this
Park anyway she says Christ I was people
chuckling tired why is nobody looking at
the people juggling fiber why are they
having a picnic next to the people
juggling fire your kid is there what are
you insane I liked the last 20 minutes
which is probably the most bullshit
eSports is entertaining just talk about
remembering the last bit cuz everyone
talks about the kung fu I remember the
kungfu and the bikes and stuff and it
movie the whole thing like that but I
was mostly dull 45 minutes at least of
just stroking Cruz's ego no by me we
always knew that I mean no no but
climbing a mountain banging the hot
chick doing this but but there's no
action really because it's not bad in
the ways I thought it would be bad that
I remember it I remember kung fu master
now that's like the good stuff I feel
like you for this koto not much of it
but John Woo be John Woo cuz I feel like
he's hampered partially by the script
that's like no we need more talking yeah
something yep there it is man weird very
weird kinda bad hopefully the new one
will be better I although I'd be amazed
if it was worse that'd be really
fascinating they find new ways but I
don't know I feel like three and this
one we're bottom of the barrel probably
so but we'll see what happens
until next time later Kittridge you've
never seen me for this fuck
you